ladies and gentlemen the engineers
drinking song
back in the day I've got quite a lot to
that song and as drinking songs go it's
not bad I caution you however before
playing this song it's in the presence
of small children audition at first some
of the some of the verses are
sufficiently gross as to make a sailor
go beyond blushing it's an interesting
song because there are an infinite
number of verses here's the mathematical
proof suppose there were a finite number
of verses then there would be a last
verse and if there were a last verse
then some drunk alumni would compose a
new one therefore there is no last verse
this size is not finite and are an
infinite number of verses I play it for
you today because I'm an engineer I like
to build stuff I build stuff out of wood
I build stuff out of metal I build stuff
out of rocks and I especially like to
write programs I don't know sometimes
people come to me and say I'm majoring
in computer science but I don't like to
write programs I've always been
mystified by that I mean if you want to
show a tough you are you can go bungee
jumping or drive a nail through your
hand or something like that instead but
I've written quite a few programs for
demonstrating our stuff in um in this
subject they're all written in Java
principally because I can therefore make
them available to you and to the rest of
the world by way of web start a few
weeks ago I was monkeying around with
the system and broke the version on the
server and within 15 minutes I got an
email from somebody and the depths of
anatolia complaining about it and asked
me to bring it back up
this particular program is patterned
after an early AI classic and it was the
business end of a program written by
Terry Winograd who became and is a
professor of computer science at
Stanford University which is on the west
coast for the used to be on the on the
strength of his with his work on the
natural language front end of this
program but the natural language part is
not what makes it of interest to it to
interest for us today it's more the
other kinds of stuff let's pile these
things up now I'm going to ask to do
something maybe put put b2 on top of b7
not bad how about b6 on b3
this programs kind of clever let me do
one more let's put b7 on b2
okay now let's see maybe b5 on b2 well
be four on b3 first maybe no I must have
clicked the wrong button down there coos
okay let's put it up
let's put b4 on b1 my mouse keeps
getting out of control
now let's put b1 on b2 this is an
example I'm actually going to work out
on the board so I see my touchpad
accidentally got activated b1 on b2
now let's ask a question
okay well alright stop
had enough of that let's see why did you
put why did you want to get rid of b4
okay
so what happens when you use software
you write yourself why did you want to
clear the top of a - did I do that
why did you clear the top b1 okay so
it's haunting me yeah so it's the
drinking song is is easily offended I
guess
but I won't I won't develop that
scenario again what I wanted to show you
is that this program looks like it's
kind of smart and it somehow can answer
questions about its own behavior you
ever read the program that's answered
questions about its own behavior
probably not what would you like to
learn how to do that ok so by the end of
the hour you'll be able to write this
program and many more like it then know
how to answer questions about their own
behavior they've been tens of thousands
of such programs written but only by
people who know this stuff I'm going to
tell you about right now ok so what I
want to do is I want to start by taking
this program apart on the board and
talking to you about the modules the
subroutines that it contains so here it
is
the first thing we need to think about
here are some blocks what happened what
has to happen if I'm going to put the
bottom block on the larger block well
first of all I have to find space for it
then I have to grasp the lower block
then I have to move it and have to
ungraspable to do so therefore I know
that the put on method has four pieces
it has to find space on the target block
it has to grasp the block that has been
commanded to move then it has to move
and then it has to ungraspable
before I got haunted by the music taking
our cue from that we know that in order
to grasp something in this particular
world you can't have anything on top of
it so grasp therefore make all clear top
in order to get stuff off from the
target object and that may happen in an
iterative loop because there may be
several things on top and then how do
you get rid of stuff well by calling get
rid out and that may go around the loop
several times and then the way you get
rid of stuff is by calling put-on
so that gives us recursion and it's from
the recursion that we get a lot of the
apparent complexity of the program's
behavior when it solves a problem now in
order to find space you also have to
call get rid up so that's where I meant
to put this other iterative loop not
down here clear top it's got the
iterative loop inside of it so that's
the structure of the program it's
extremely simple
and you might say to me well how can you
get such apparently complex looking
behavior out of such a simple program or
legitimate question but before we tackle
that one head-on I'd like to do a
simulation of this program on a very
simple blocks problem and it's the one I
almost showed you but it goes like this
here's B one we'll call this B X because
I forgot its name here's B Y and here's
B 2 and the task is to put b1 on b2 and
according to our system diagram that
results in four calls to subroutines we
have to find space we have to grasp a 1
we have to move and then we ungraspable
now the way we grasp something is the
first thing we have to do is clear off
its top so grasp calls clear top and
clear top and turn calls get rid of
and let me see let me keep track of
these this is clearing the top of B 2 or
B 1 and this is getting rid of B X and
the way we get rid of B X is by putting
the X on the table and then that in turn
call causes calls to another fine space
another grasp another move and another
on grasp so that's a little trace of the
program as it works on this simple
problem so how does it go about not
answering the questions that I
demonstrated to you a moment ago you
must do that by using this trace so how
for example does it answer the question
why did you get rid of BX manasa what do
you think how can I answer that question
so it goes up one level and reports what
it sees so it says and said in the
demonstration I got rid of BX because I
was trying to clear the top of b1 so if
I were to say why did you clear the top
of b1 it would say because I was trying
to grasp it if I were to say why did you
grasp e1 it would say because I was
putting b1 on b2 if I say why did you
put b1 on b2 he would say slavery slave
because you told me to okay so that's
how it deals with with why questions how
about how questions Timothy what do you
think about that one how would it go
about answering a question about how you
did something you have thought yeah but
how would it do that how the program do
that we know that answering white
question makes it go up one level how
does it answer how question Sebastian
you go down one level so you started
started off all the way up here with a
put-on
she will say oh I did these four things
you say why did you grass b1 and we'll
say because I was trying to clear it
stop
why did you clear it stop because I was
trying to get rid of it why were you
trying to get rid of it because I was
trying to put it on the table so that's
how it answers how questions like going
down in this tree in this trace of
program action so as to see how things
are put together what are these things
that are being put together what's the
word I've been avoiding so as to bring
it this to a crescendo or dot what are
these objectives these things it wants
to do their goals so this thing is
leaving a trace which is a goal tree
does that sound familiar three days ago
we talked about gold trees in connection
with integration so this thing is
building a gold tree also known as an
and/or tree
so this must be a nan tree and if this
is an entry other any endnotes sure
there's one right there so do you think
then that you can answer questions about
your own behavior as long as we build an
ad or tree
sure does this mean the integration
program could answer questions about its
own behavior sure because they both
build goal trees and whatever you got a
goal tree you can answer certain kinds
of questions about your own behavior so
let me see if in fact that's if it
really does build itself a up a goal
tree as it solves problems so this time
we'll put b6 on b3 this time we'll watch
it develop its goal tree
so in contrast to the simple example I
was working on the board this gets to be
a pretty complicated goal tree but I can
still answer questions about behavior
for example I could say why did you put
the six on v3 as you told me to all
right so the complexity of the behavior
is largely a consequence not of the
complexity of the program in this
particular case but the building of this
giant goal tree is a consequence of the
complexity of the problem and this
brings us to one of our bridges rather
early on to one of the goal star ideas
of today and this gold star idea goes
back to a lecture given in the late 60s
by herb Simon who is the first Nobel
laureate in the pseudo Nobel Prize for
economics that right Bob was he the
first now he's the first winner of the
Nobel Prize pseudo Nobel Prize in
Economics and in this lecture which was
entitled Sciences they artificial he
said imagine that you're looking on a
beach at the path of an ant and he said
well you know the path of the ant looks
extremely complicated and you're tempted
to think the ant is some kind of genius
or over a monster brain ant but in fact
when you take a closer look that you
discover is that there are a bunch of
pebbles on the beach and all the ant is
doing is avoiding those pebbles on its
way home so the complexity of the
behavior said Simon is a consequence of
the complexity of the environment not
the complexity of the program so that's
the metaphor of Simon's aunt and what
what it says is that the complexity of
the behavior
is the max of the complexity of the
program and the complexity of the
environment
so that's something we'll see many times
during the rest of the semester complex
behavior simple program you think it's
going to be complicated turns out to be
simple because the problem is that as
the complexity not the not the program
so that brings us to check box three and
today's talking there's a little bit of
a seam here because now I want to stop
talking about goal centered programming
and start talking about rule-based
expert systems the rule-based expert
systems were developed in a burst of
enthusiasm about the prospects for
commercial applications of artificial
intelligence in the mid-1980s and at
that time it was supposed lengthy
articles are written that you can
account for useful aspects of human
intelligence by writing all the
knowledge in the form of simple rules so
if this is true then that's true if you
want to achieve this then do that but
all the knowledge had to be encapsulated
in the form of simple rules so what
might you want to do with this all sorts
of things thousands of these systems
were written as I indicated before but
here's an example I'm going to work out
an example having to do with
identification and this so this example
is patterned off of a classic program
strangely also written at Stanford
called Meissen it was developed to
diagnose bacterial infections of the
blood so you come in you've got some
horrible disease and the doctor gets
curious about what antibiotic would be
perfect for your disease and starts
asking you a lot of questions so I'm
going to deal with that because that
world has all kinds of unpronounceable
terms like bacteria IDs and anaerobic
and stuff like that so it's completely
analogous to talk about identifying
animals in a little zoo sort of a small
town type of zoo so I'm going to suggest
that we write down on a piece of paper
all the things we can observe about an
animal and then we'll try to figure out
what what the animal is so I don't know
what can we start with has hair then
there are some characteristics of the
following form has claws sharp teeth and
forward twenty eyes and these are all
characteristics of carnivores we happen
to have forward-pointing eyes too but
that's more because we used to swing
around the trees a lot and we needed the
stereo vision and we don't have the
claws on the sharp teeth to go with it
but anyhow those are typically
characteristics of carnivores as is
eating meat and this particular little
animal we're looking at is also got
spots and it's very fast what is it
oh well everybody says it's a cheetah
let's see how the program would figure
that out well a program might say let's
see if it has hair then rule one says
that that means it must be a mammal we
can imagine another rule that says if
you have sharp claws sharp teeth and
forward-pointing eyes then you're a
carnivore and I'm using sort of hardware
notation here that's a NAND gate right
so that means that we have to have all
of these characteristics before we will
conclude that the animal is a carnivore
now this animal has been also observed
to eat meat so that means we've got
extra evidence that the animal is
carnivorous and now because the animal
is a mammal and the carnivore and it has
spots and it's very fast and the animal
is a cheetah
I hope all of our effort and students
agree that that must be a cheetah it's a
small zoo I mean it's big zoo who knows
what it is it's probably got some
unpronounceable name there are there's
possibilities but for a small zoo that
will do so we have now written down in
the form of these and gates several
rules r1 r2 and there needs to be an end
gate here that's our 3 + r4
all of which are indicated all of what
you indicate to this animal is a cheetah
so we built ourself a little rule-based
expert system can recognize exactly one
animal but you can imagine filling up
filling out their system with other
rules so you could recognize giraffes
and penguins and all the other sorts of
things just find a small zoo so when you
have a system like this that works as
I've indicated then what we're going to
call that we're going to give that a
special name now we're going to call out
a forward chaining rule-based because it
uses rules expert system
and we're going to put expert in
parentheses because when these things
were developed for marketing reasons
they call them expert systems instead of
novice systems but are they really
experts in a human sense not really
because they have these knee-jerk rules
they're not equipped with anything you
might want to call common sense they
don't have an ability to deal with
previous cases like we do when we go to
medical school so they really ought to
be called rule-based novice systems
because they reason like novices on the
basis of rules but the tradition is to
call them rule-based expert systems and
this one works forward from the facts we
give it to the conclusion off on the
right that's why it's a forward chaining
system okay can this system answer
questions about its own behavior
Quadra what do you think why
because it looks like a gold tree this
is a fact building adultery because each
of these rules that require several
things to be true is creating an EndNote
and each of these situations here where
you have multiple reasons for believing
the thing as a Carter well that's
creating an or node and we already know
that you can answer questions about your
own behavior
if you leave behind a trace of a gold
tree so look at this if I say to it why
were you interested in the animals
clause because I was trying to see if it
was a carnivore how did you know that
the animal is a mammal because it has
hair why did you think it was a cheetah
because it's a mammal a carnivore has
scottson very fast so by working forward
and backward in this this gold frame
this too can answer questions about its
own behavior so now you know how going
forward you can write programs that
answer questions about their behavior
either you write the subroutine so that
each one is wrapped around a goal so
you've got goal centered programming or
you build a so-called expert system
using rules in which case it's easy to
make it leave behind a trace of a goal
free which makes it possible to answer
questions about its own behavior just as
this block scroll program did but now a
little more vocabulary I'm going to save
time by erasing all of these things that
I previously drew by way of connections
and I'm going to approach this zoo in a
little different way I'm going to not
ask any questions about the animal
instead I'm going to say mummy is this
thing I'm looking at a cheetah and how
would mommy go about figuring it out in
her head she would say well I don't know
if it's going to be a cheetah then it
must be the case that it's a carnivore
and it must be the case that it has
spots and it must be the case that it's
very fast so so far what we've
established is that if it's going to be
a cheetah it has to have the four
characteristics that mommy finds behind
this rule are four so instead of working
forward from facts what I'm going to do
is work backward from a hypothesis so
here the hypothesis is this thing is a
cheetah how do I go about showing
whether that's true or not well I
haven't done anything so far because all
I know is a cheetah if all of these
things are true but are they true well
to find out if it's a mammal I can use
rule 1 and if I know we can determine
that the animal has hair then that part
of it is taken care of and I can
similarly work my way back through part
of war by saying well it's a carnivore
if it has claws sharp teeth and
forward-pointing eyes and in as much as
the animal in question does then I'm
through I know it's a carnivore I don't
have to go through and show that it's a
carnivore another way so I never
actually asked questions about whether
it eats meat finally the final two
conditions are met by just an inspection
of the animal that is to say it's in the
database I don't have to use any rules
to determine that the animal has spots
and it's very fast so now I've got
everything in place
it's a cheetah because it's a cart of
war because it has claws sharp teeth and
forward-pointing eyes and all the rest
of this stuff is similarly determined by
going backwards backwards from the
hypothesis toward the facts instead of
from the facts forward to the
conclusions so going building a system
that works like that I have a backward a
backward chaining rule-based expert
system but there's a very important
characteristic of the system in both
backward and forward mode and that is
that this thing is a deduction system
that's because it's working with facts
to produce new facts and we have a
deduction system you can never take
anything away but these rule-based
systems are also used in another mode
where it's possible to take something
away see in in fact world the deduction
world you're talking about proving
things and once you prove something is
true you can't it can't be false if it
is you've got a contradiction in your
system but if you think of this as a
programming language if you think of
using rules as a plug programming
language then you can think of arranging
it so these rules add or subtract from a
database let me show you an example of
this couple of systems first of all
since I've talked about the myosin
system let me show you
an example of a mice and dialogue it's a
mice and dialogue and you can see the
appearance of words you have to go to
medical school to learn and here's a
typical myosin rule just like the rules
for doing zoo analysis only a more
complicated domain but here's another
example of a system that was written not
in the 80s but just a couple of years
ago by a student in the architecture
department PhD thesis he was interested
in the architecture of a Portuguese
architect named Caesar and Caesar has
done a lot of mass housing stuff and
Caesar has the idea that you ought to be
able to design your own house and so
Jose de Arte a Portuguese student and
the PhD student architecture wrote a
rule-based system that was capable of
designing Caesar like houses in response
to the requirements and recommendations
and desires of the people who are going
to occupy the houses so the most
compelling part of this day of this
exercise was that Duarte took some of
the designs of the program mix them up
with some of the designs of Caesar and
put them in front of Caesar and said
which ones did you do and Caesar
couldn't tell so somehow the rule-based
system that was built using this kind of
technology was sufficient to confuse
even the expert that they were patterned
after but this program is a little
complicated that too has its own
specialized lingo so I'm not going to
talk about it in detail but rather talk
instead about an analogous problem and
that is a problem that everyone is faced
at one point or another
and that is the problem of putting
groceries in a bag at a grocery store
it's the same thing right instead of
putting rooms in a house you're putting
groceries in a bag and there must be
some rules about how to do that in fact
maybe some of you have been professional
grocery store beggars
aerials of groceries the professional
bagger your which one yeah what is your
name Lisa okay we've got two two of
professional grocery store beggars and
I'm going to be now simulating a null
highly paid knowledge engineer desirous
of building a program that knows how to
bag groceries so I'm going to visit your
site Market Basket and I'm going to ask
Lisa now fearful of losing her job if
she would tell me about how she bags
Brussels
so could you suggest a rule large items
in the ba si si I'm highly paid
knowledge engineer because I translate
what she said and into an ephemeral so
if large then bottom so now so how about
you Ariel you got a suggestion how to
bag groceries if small then on they said
if you got anything else you can tell me
in the same bag so if heavy greater than
three then no bag or something like that
okay is that all we're going to be able
to is anybody else want to volunteer so
have you tagged a bag groceries soon
it's outsourcing no switches on the
bottom that's good
tomatoes now there's very different
thing about species and tomatoes because
tomato is specific and squishy isn't one
Tennessee of MIT students of course is
that we all tend to generalize I once
knew a professor in a Sloan School who
seemed real smart then I figured out
what he did if I were to say I'm
thinking about a red apple
it's sit back up and say oh I see you're
contemplating colored fruit today just
taking it up one level of abstraction in
an ingenious idea also was able to talk
for an hour after you drew a triangle on
the board amazing people anyhow how
where were we
oh yes bagging groceries so we're making
some progress but not as much as I would
like and so in order to really make
progress on tasks like this you have to
exercise you have to know about some
principles of knowledge engineering so
principle number one which I've listed
over here as part of a gold star idea is
deal with specific cases so while you're
at the site if all you do is talk to the
experts like Lisa an Ariel all you're
going to get is vague generalities
because they won't think of everything
so what you do is you say well let me
watch you on the line and then you'll
see that they have to have some way of
dealing with the milk and they will see
they have to have some way of dealing
with the potato chips nobody mentioned
potato chips except insofar as they
might be squishy squishy I don't have a
definition for squishy no one talked
about the macaroni and no one talked
about the motor oil this is a
convenience store probably don't want
that the same bag with a meat
and then no one talked about canned
stuff here's a can of Olives
so by looking at specific cases you will
elicit from people knowledge they
otherwise would not have thought to give
you okay
that's rule that's a knowledge
engineering rule number one and within a
very few minutes you'll have all three
knowledge engineering rules and be
prepared to be a highly paid knowledge
engineer rule heuristic let's call these
heuristics
ristic number one specific cases mystic
number two is ask questions about things
that appear to be the same but are
actually handled differently so there's
some bird's eye frozen peas and here
some fresh-cut sweet peas and to me a
person who's never touched a grocery bag
of my life maybe I'm from Mars I can't
tell the difference they're both peas
but I observe that the experts are
handling these objects differently so I
say why did you handle those peas
differently from those peas and what do
they say once canned and once frozen so
what happens
bingo I've got some new words in my
vocabulary and those new vocabulary
words are going to give me power over
the domain because I can now use those
words in my rules and I can write rules
like if frozen then put them all
together in a little plastic bag
actually that's too complicated but
that's what we end up doing right why do
we put them all together in a little
plastic bag what's that well there are
two explanations the there's the MIT
explanation we know that the temperature
flow is equal to the fourth power of the
temperature difference in the surface
area and all that kind of stuff
we want to get them all together at a
ball
here the normal explanation is that
they're going to melt anyway so they
might as well not get everything else
wet right so that's heuristic number two
and actually there's a heuristic number
three that I just want to relate to you
for the first time because I have been
dealing with it a lot over this past
summer heuristic number three is you
build a system and you see when it
cracks and when it cracks is when you
don't have one of the rules you need in
order to execute the index in order in
order to get the program to execute as
you want it to execute so if I were to
write a grocery store bagging program
and have it bag some groceries again
eventually it would either make a
mistake or come to a grinding halt and
bingo I know that there's a risking rule
isn't that what happens when you do a
problem set and you hit an impasse
you're performing an experiment on
yourself and you're discovering that you
don't have the whole program in fact
obviously this is a gold star idea
having to do with engineering yourself
because all of these things that you can
do for knowledge engineering are things
you can do when you learn a new subject
yourself because essentially you're
making yourself into an expert system
when you're learning circuit theory or
electromagnetism or something of that
sort you're saying to yourself well
let's look at some specific cases well
what are the vocabulary items here that
tell me why this problem is different
from that problem oh this is a cylinder
instead of a sphere or you're working
the problem set and discovery you can't
work the problem you need to get another
another chunk of knowledge that makes it
possible for you to do it
so this sort of thing what you think of
and primarily is mechanism mystics for
doing knowledge engineering are also
mechanisms for making yourself in making
yourself smarter
so that concludes what I want to talk
with you about today but the bottom line
is that if you build a rule-based expert
system it can answer questions about its
own behavior if you build a program
that's centered on goals it can answer
questions about its own behavior if you
build an integration program it can
answer questions about its own behavior
and if you want to build one of these
systems and you need to extract
knowledge from an expert you need to
approach it with these kinds of
heuristics because the expert won't
think what to tell you unless you elicit
that information by specific cases by
asking questions about differences and
by ultimately doing some experiments to
see where your program is cracked so
that really concludes what I had to say
except I want to ask the question is
this all we need to know about human
intelligence can these things be are
these things really smart and the
traditional answer is no not really
smart because their intelligence is the
sort of thin veneer and once when you
try to get underneath it they tend to
they tend to as written they tend to
crack for example we talked about a rule
we could talk about a rule that knows
that you should put the potato chips on
the top of the bag but a program that
knows that we have no idea why you would
want to put in potato chips on top of
the bag they wouldn't know that if you
put them on the bottom of the bag
they'll get crushed and it wouldn't know
that if they get crushed the customer
will get angry because people don't like
the crushed potato chips so that's what
I mean when I say the knowledge of these
things tends to be a veneer
so the Meissen program during debugging
once prescribed a barrel of penicillin
to to be administered to a patient for
his disease they don't know they don't
have any common sense so the question
then becomes well I don't know
does rule-based due to rules have
anything to do with with common sense
and I'm becoming a little bit agnostic
on that subject because there are
certain indications there are certain
situations in which rules could be said
to play a role in our ordinary
understanding of things would you like
to see a demonstration what I'm going to
show you when Eclipse boots up well
before I make any promises let me see if
I'm actually connected to the web
a mighty good MIT guest yeah that's me
sounds good
okay I just tested the system and I've
seen it is actually connected to the web
I'm going to adjust some systems options
here we'll get rid of the text box and
we'll get rid of this or changes scale a
little bit and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to read a little synopsis
of the Macbeth plot now your MIT
students I'm sure you're all classical
educated and very familiar with
Shakespearean plots so I'm going to read
one and read a version of a Macbeth plot
and it's going to go along like this
it's basically reading a rule base so
far
and pretty soon it's going to get beyond
the rule base and start reading the
Macbeth story and there it is it's read
to make that story let me show you what
they make that story looks like as it's
actually retained by the system that's
it
you can read that okay you run out of
time because the machines already
finished takes about five seconds to
read the story now as you look at this
little synopsis of Macbeth there are a
couple of things to note for one thing
it says that Duncan is murdered Duncan I
hope this doesn't bother you Duncan is
murdered by Macbeth but at no time does
it say that Duncan is dead but you know
Duncan's dead because he was murdered
if murdered then dead
so if you look a little further down
what you see is that Macduff kills
Macbeth fourth line up from the bottom
why didn't Macbeth why to Macduff kills
Macbeth doesn't say why in the story but
you have no trouble figuring out this
because he got angry and when you get
angry you don't necessarily kill
somebody but it's possible so now that
you see what's in the story let me take
you back to this display it's what we
call an elaboration graph and when I
blow it up you can see that there's some
familiar looking things in there
for example up here in the left hand
corner
Macbeth murders Duncan right over there
and over here Macbeth kills Macduff
kills Macbeth if you look at what is a
consequence of that it looks like there
must be a rule that says if you murder
somebody you harm them and if you murder
somebody then they're dead and one
reason why you might kill somebody is
because they angered you and if you go
the other way one consequence of killing
somebody is you harm them and that they
get then they die too and if you harm
somebody they get angry and their state
goes negative
so that suggests that there are some
things that we have in our heads that
are very compiled and very strangely
enough very rule like in in their
character now to close I'm just going to
read Hamlet the Hamlet demonstration is
much like the Macbeth one in fact Hamlet
and Macbeth are very alike in their plot
but there's one thing that's well
illustrated by our particular capturing
of Hamlet here and that is that you'll
note that the ratio of brave stuff to
white stuff is considerable the gray
stuff is stuff that has been deduced by
rules and the reason there's so much
great stuff in this Hamlet story is
because everybody's related to everybody
else so when you kill anybody you
irritate everybody else so look at that
a few white things those are the things
that are explicit in the story and lots
of great stuff so what this is
suggesting is that when we tell a story
it's mostly a matter of controlled
hallucination I know what rules are in
your head so I can take advantage of
that in telling the story and not have
to tell you anything I'm sure you're
ready to know and so that's why we've
discovered that storytelling is largely
a matter of just controlling how you're
going along I kind of control
hallucination
you